[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
just like old times
the tartan army wembley bound and
scotland
desperately seeking a result
we are leaving proud caledonia in
edinburgh this was journey's start
or even a train trip needs a team talk
bonnie scotland
[Applause]
the road to wembley rekindles age-old
it does get the hairs on the back of
your neck
moving especially once you're in that
stadium
nowadays we allow the english fans to
come to wembley as well and it's not
just full of scottish fans
it's the magic scene scotland playing
against your oldest
uh competitor i'd like it to go well i
think it will i've got my hope set
so yeah i think it'll go well we really
need to get right in there from the word
go
and predict a 2-1 win to scotland
scotland fans have traveled to london by
rail
road and air up to twenty thousand are
expected to be in the city
but only three thousand have tickets for
the stadium
london's mayor city cannes had appealed
to scots not to
travel without a ticket or a safe place
to watch the game
a fit again kieran tierney was among the
scotland players who trained before
heading south yesterday
without at least a point from tonight's
game he
and they will return north contemplating
an
early exit we hope to start just as
quick as england do
we'll go out there we'll try and get on
the front foot as early as possible try
and get a hold of the ball
we'll try and make the the players will
try and make themselves feel comfortable
on the pitch on the stage
and if we can get off to a quick start
they'll be good for us
after their opening win over croatia
england start tonight as hot favorites
even if their manager is playing it cool
our objective is qualification so that's
that's what we've got to to focus on i
thought
um in the past we've done that well i
thought we did that very well on sunday
you know sunday was a big occasion for
everybody it is the great
wembley pilgrimage a place where scots
have enjoyed some of their finest
football moments
the tartan army has long felt a sense of
belonging here
for itself and for this fixture for them
footballs coming home from home
james matthews sky news edinburgh